[Música]
y seguimos con nuestros análisis en
directo américa con mar romero sala marc
vamos a hablar de algo que todavía no
hemos superado salimos de una pandemia
ya dos años en confinamiento todo lo que
nos ha traído en nuestra salud mental
para ahora caer en una guerra le
pregunto cómo afecta entonces la guerra
el conflicto una vida hay quienes sufren
múltiples son maneras hoy vamos a hablar
por supuesto de la salud mental si
empezamos hablando de la salud mental
primero de las personas que están
sufriendo este conflicto que son sobre
todo los ucranianos empezar diciendo que
también es una diferencia ya que tan
temprano en un conflicto estemos
hablando de esto suele ser un poco más
difícil yo no suele ser una prioridad de
al menos en estos contextos pero
empecemos también diciendo una cosa que
está clara y es que las guerras son
máquinas de crear trastornos de salud
mental es indiscutible las cifras más
recientes que existen recopiladas por la
organización mundial de la salud en 2019
dicen que al menos el 22 por ciento de
la población que viene que vive en zonas
de conflicto tienen algún transtorno de
salud mental eso es aproximadamente una
de cada cinco mucha gente el principal
factor identificado es la incertidumbre
no la incertidumbre de qué pasará con la
propia vida cuando se está en el frente
pero también la incertidumbre de las
personas que están migrando de los
refugiados la incertidumbre de la
pobreza que conlleva un conflicto armado
en estos datos estamos contando
depresión ansiedad estrés postraumático
bipolaridad y esquizofrenia estas son
los cinco trastornos que se cuentan y
además es importante destacar que antes
se creía que era una de cada 14 personas
en zonas de conflicto que sufrían esto
2019 se vio que la cifra era mucho más
alta hay un vídeo también es circulando
en todas las redes sociales de un niño
cruzando la frontera de ucrania creo que
es a polonia y la verdad que es
desgarrador imagínense ese niño cuando
quieres que todo ese trauma pues jamás
se le se le va a olvidar porque además
el niño estaba llorando
desconsoladamente pues por supuesto
sabremos ahora hablaremos de ello ahora
ha pasado con su familia mari cómo se
comporta se comparan entonces esta cifra
respecto a la población general pues es
importante tenerlo en cuenta porque en
todos lados hay trastorno salud mental
entonces para hacernos una idea de esta
magnitud tenemos que compararlo con cómo
es la media global no hay un ejemplo por
ejemplo con la depresión
por rangos de edad en este gráfico ven
en azul por ejemplo el número de años de
incapacidad vividos por culpa de
depresión por cada mil personas en zonas
de conflicto y en rojo es la media
global vemos que es sistemáticamente más
alto en todos los rangos de edad excepto
en los primeros años de vida hay que
tener en cuenta dos cosas uno que las
enfermedades mentales suelen todavía
estar infradiagnosticadas y dos que no
hace falta tener un diagnóstico de
enfermedad de salud mental para tener
una afectación a esta salud mental es
como por ejemplo con la alimentación uno
puede estar mal alimentado esto puede
derivar en enfermedades pero eso no
quiere decir que ya no sea un problema
de base no entonces importante también
hablar de por ejemplo síndromes como el
de estrés psicológico agudo que son
sentimientos negativos que pueden
abrumar a las personas y pueden
dificultar el funcionamiento diario pero
que no son una enfermedad como tal estas
cifras por ahora son de enfermedades con
diagnóstico a largo plazo mar cómo
afecta todo esto a la población pues
muchas veces pensamos en las guerras
como en términos de muertes de heridas
de las casas que se destruyen de los
puentes que caen o de todo eso que
desaparece pero qué pasa al final con
los que sobreviven con los que se quedan
que sí permanece 50 años después de la
segunda guerra mundial todavía vemos que
hay porcentajes significativos de
supervivientes este estudio que estamos
citando aquí que tienen todavía estrés
postraumático una enfermedad que es
totalmente tratable no en afganistán por
ejemplo un país que ha vivido años y
años de circunstancias traumáticas la
mitad de la población tiene este estrés
psicológico agudo que estábamos hablando
cada situación es diferente y cada país
tiene circunstancias diferentes pero es
importante ponerse desde ya manos a la
obra con el conflicto en ucrania mar
ahora sí vamos a hablar de lo que yo le
estaba adelantando todavía pensando a
largo plazo cómo impacta a toda esta
situación en los niños y las niñas es
precisamente lo que estabas diciendo tú
no la mayoría además de estos niños y
niñas que estamos viendo ahora se están
convirtiendo en refugiados y en
migrantes y son las futuras generaciones
que son vitales para la reconstrucción y
para lo que venga después de esto sea lo
que sea y llegue cuando llegue en
general la población menor de edad tiene
menos herramientas para lidiar con esta
incertidumbre de la guerra también tiene
menos herramientas para comprender lo
que está sucediendo aunque eso a veces
alimentado por los propios adultos que
en un intento de protegerlas pueden
llegar a esconder lo que está sucediendo
o maquillar lo de alguna manera y eso
contribuye a esa incertidumbre en los
menores de edad hay un factor muy
importante un estudio de col de hecho
por la universidad de columbia en 2018
en campamentos de refugiados que
concluía además que la existencia de
depresión en un adulto llegaba a
triplicar el riesgo de ansiedad en los
adolescentes que tuvieran a su cargo
entonces vemos que esto de la salud
mental al final es una cosa conjunta de
toda la sociedad de todas las familias
es vital ofrecer atención a todos estos
y también todo esto llega como también
lo estaba diciendo después de la
pandemia de kobe 19 que tanto nos ha
afectado más y que parece que nosotros
como humanidad no aprendemos de todas
las desgracias que nos pasan no y nos
afecta tanto a las personas que lo están
viviendo no en ucrania rusia los países
que acogen a refugiados todos han
atravesado la pandemia como los
espectadores periodistas que estamos
hablando todo el día de éstas con exacto
pero yo creo que si hay algo que hemos
aprendido al menos a raíz de la pandemia
o alguna parte positiva y es que pues
todo lo que estamos hablando de la salud
mental en este momento al final uno de
los problemas alrededor de estos
trastornos o de este malestar es el
estigma que existe y yo creo que es un
estigma que se ha resquebrajado con dos
años en los que todos nos hemos visto
afectados por la pandemia un ejemplo es
pues este segmento que estamos haciendo
en este mismo momento no en contextos de
conflicto podemos pensar que la
supervivencia que el último minuto que
los avances de las tropas son lo más
importante pero es importante hablar a
largo plazo la salud mental nos habla a
largo plazo de garantizar la vida y de
asegurar un futuro donde la gente vaya a
ser capaz de reconstruir vínculos y de
reconstruir vidas y ojalá que todo eso
pase en la realidad y no sé que eso
sobre todo en el papel gracias mar como
siempre por los análisis que usted ha
hecho desde que inició este conflicto en
ucrania pasamos a hablar ahora con
nuestra segunda